I think one issue is you know what type
of binding this concept legally binding
was discussed a lot when I was in the
daily sustainable development conference
recently only two weeks ago and
obviously it has become a notion that
some people are dead against and others
are absolutely for the question is how
can you make systems and approaches and
parts of a broader global deal where as
many parts as possible are credible
where you have accountability where they
can be measured and where countries have
what we will call real commitments the
question is one of seeking to find ways
to overcome the big gaps between a key
countries on the notion and on the
interpretation of legally binding we
have examples of legally binding
agreement of a global or international
nature which are not followed up and we
have other agreements which are followed
up without them being in the strict
sense and you know legal sense binding
so I what we have to look for is
sufficient credibility consensus
building and and combining the how far
countries are able and willing to go if
it is within what we need which is to
get to the goal of no more than two
degrees increase by 2050
well I think what people and NGOs and
others are and even you know businesses
and private initiatives that are taken
are important indeed they are important
also because they inspire public opinion
building they inspire leaders so not
only in themselves but in the way that
they create the building of more
consensus it's important but I don't
think it in itself will be enough unless
we have leaders committing and
committing across borders and businesses
that have to take into consideration
what the world is expecting from them
not only at national level but
multinational companies having to look
at some kind of international framework
that they have to abide by unless we get
there I think we will always have a gap
we need to have a building of public
opinion and consensus that is part of
what leaders can build them as they also
move together and see more eye to eye on
this issue
you